I've got I've got an interesting voicemail to play
for you. You can leave a voicemail any time at
two one nine two David P.. It's about a wacky
congresswoman, Lauren Bobert and her education
and or lack thereof. And there's a few things
here I want to talk about. So let's listen.
Good evening, David. My name is Rae. I'm
calling in regards to Congresswoman Bulbar.
I was doing some research on her
and I stumbled across the fact that
she received her J.D., not her high school diploma
in May of twenty twenty. Right. Yet her office
and her people have not confirmed nor denied that
she received it, nor if she even has one. So there
seems to be something not right with that based
on the fact that if she had received it in May,
you know, they would have to basically just say,
yeah, this happened and that's OK. But they seem
to not even want to address it, which could mean
to me possibly that she doesn't even have one.
So maybe that's something that our viewers
can dig deeper into this and and just find
out what's going on with this person, because
she's she's totally. Fit to be in Congress.
So, yeah, now.
So listen, a lot of what the caller
says is correct. Lauren Bobert is completely unfit
to be in Congress. It's not because she doesn't
have a high school diploma or college education
necessarily. She's unfit because she's a radical
insurrectionist. And part of the problem we're
trying to solve rather than any possible solution.
Now, in terms of the stuff, the caller is correct.
It is asserted that Lauren Bobert got her GED.
The story of Lauren Bobert is something like and
I'm paraphrasing here, she was in high school,
but she dropped out to work at McDonalds.
I don't remember if it was to support her
family or what what the reasoning was. And
then she later went back and got her GED
a few months ago, reportedly getting it in May of
twenty twenty. I have no idea. It's I've not seen
what we might call proof that she really got
her GED. She may have it. She may not. But but
here's the thing. This is not about education
shaming. Lauren Bobert is an ignorant person,
regardless of what kind of degree she has.
A year ago, I met someone with a Ph.D. in biology
who maybe when it came to biology, was an absolute
genius, but was a complete and total idiot
when it came to political science, economics,
cultural issues, sociology. I mean, it was just
I felt like I was talking to someone who
who seemed to lack education altogether.
So, you know, when it comes to biology,
maybe this person was great, maybe not
having or not having a GED, high school diploma,
college degree, master's degree, Ph.D. It is not
proof that you are or aren't fit to be an elected
official. The sad truth is that whether Lauren
Bobert does or doesn't have a GED, she is not
someone that should be involved in making law
or leading the country whatsoever. Now, on the
other hand, Bill Gates dropped out of college.
He's more than well qualified to be a member
of Congress or senator. He understands the
scientific method. He understands how to think
about problems. He understands how to manage
people and projects and on and on and on. And
so for me, the problem is that for some of these
folks, the lack of education has become sort of a
point of pride where voters are drawn to someone
because they've fallen for this idea that higher
education is liberal indoctrination, conspiracy
theory thing. And they seem to think that by
electing someone who's not gone to college,
that they're owning the Libs in some way. I think
it's important that we on the left don't focus on
education shaming. There are plenty of people
without significant degrees of formal education
who are very smart and would be great leaders
for this country. And that would be fantastic.
And as I've said before, in general, we should be
diversifying the types of folks that represent us.
We don't want just former lawyers and former CEOs
and career politicians. I would love teachers.
I would love to get people from science. I would
like people, you know, on and on and on. But the
idea of going to people without formal education,
merely because you think education is liberal,
indoctrination is a problem. And so if if Lauren
Beaugard is lying about her GED, that's a major
problem. If Lauren Bobert is unfit to be a member
of Congress because of her ideas and the fact that
she brings no knowledge whatsoever about policy
and that's the case. She shouldn't be in the
House of Representatives and she shouldn't.
But I think we need to look more deeply,
much the same way as Trump as a candidate.
Trump if Trump had run as a Democrat.
He'd have had no shot of winning the primary and
Trump ism wouldn't be what it is, Trump ism is
what it is because Trump ran as a Republican
and the Republican electorate fell for it.
I liked it. I was drawn to it partially to,
quote, own the Libs, as they would often say.
And so a lot of the problem is the electorate,
the electorate that sees someone as incompetent
as Lauren Bobert and regardless of her formal
education level, says, let's choose her. That's
what we need to solve. That's a bigger cultural
issue. We've got a great bonus show for you today.